the workshop micro careful of will how's
about datastreams
thanks for the introduction I will talk
about algorithms for processing massive
data streams and in general this these
two talks will be organized as follows I
will start with some basic classical
techniques for approximating statistical
properties of large streams of datasets
large sweet streams of data items and
once we develop these techniques I will
show some of the more recent
applications to processing massive
graphs in dynamic streams so
specifically I will talk about
connectivity and related questions in
the first part and I will show how to
construct spectacled approximations to
graphs in dynamic streams through
sketching in the second part of this
talk oh and you please stop me with any
questions all right so this is about the
streaming model of computation
what is the streaming model of
computation it's a model for processing
massive data sets and in the small we
think of the algorithm as observing a
very long stream of data items this data
items could be a lot of things for
example IP packets tweets search queries
and whatnot well the classical streaming
question is the following as our
algorithm is scanning this very long
stream of data items it is limited in
its space usage so it can't store the
entire stream it has to maintain a small
a small amount of bits representation of
the stream at all times
and at any point we should be able to
stop this algorithm and query some basic
statistics of the data stream some basic
statistics include things like the
number of distinct elements that we have
seen so far or something about the
distribution of frequency state of the
data items for instance okay well this
was the classical motivation for the
streaming model and more recently the
question of processing massive graphs
and the data stream model has received a
lot of attention these days we care
about more complicated statistics of
data streams so here I think of this
very long stream of data items let's say
being a very long stream of edges of a
graph and what we want is to be able to
process such streams where the edges
have arrived and possibly depart and at
the same time at every point in time we
want to be able to stop our algorithm
and ask it about basic graph parameters
for the graph that we have received so
far for instance perhaps approximate the
cut structure of the graph spectral
structure of the graph something about
the shortest path metric matching size
vertex cover and other questions okay
good so in this talk I will first
explain some of the basics of how do you
solve problems from class one and then
talk about graph analysis so I'll start
with the basic stream statistics and
specifically I will remind you how
classical sketching algorithms such as
distinct elements a mess sketch and l0
samplers work and at the same time I'll
tell you about some of the recent
results on those as well okay so what is
the distinct elements problem there is
probably the most basic streaming out
here our algorithm is given a single
pass over a collection of data items I 1
I 2 through I something these data items
think of them as say integers between 1
and N and let's assume that we know n
the size of the stream is fully
unbounded and what we want is to scan
the stream and at the end of the day I
want to be able to know how many
distinct elements we have seen so far
and we want to have small small storage
so for example the trivial way of
solving this problem is to just store
the entire stream sort of hash the data
items that will be prohibitively
expensive it would take space
proportional to the number of these data
items we want space poly logarithmic in
the size of the in the size of the
string
okay so here's a pictorial
representation for instance suppose that
our data items come from a universe of
size 10 so there are numbers between 1
and 1 and 10 and our stream is just a
sequence of such numbers so here they
are coming in at the bottom the sequence
is 3 4 3 to 10 3 etc and as the stream
is coming in here on the slide I'm also
maintaining the frequency frequency
vector representation for that stream
and particular here what this shows is
the number of times every given item
appeared for example the item 1 appeared
twice item 2 appeared five times etc
okay well as we see if the stream is
reasonably long at the same time the
number of distinct elements here is 8
sort of our task is to output 8 on a
stream like this ok so why do we care
about such problems of the classical
application is monitoring network
statistics for instance suppose that we
have a router that here it is pictured
on the slide and the surround is a
device that has a limited amount of fuzz
the space space available and the router
is observing some IP packets that are
coming going through it if every IP
packet goes from some source to some
destination and the IP flows can be
encoded by a virus matrix or the rows
correspond to all the possible source IP
addresses and the columns to a the
possible destination IP addresses so as
the packets come in we can think of
updating this matrix similarly to the
vector on the previous slide ok the end
of the day we want to be able to figure
out how many distinct source a source
destination pairs have been engaged in
communication through this router
ok so of course the router can't store
the entire flow to my space and we want
to space poly logarithmic in the size of
the universe the size of the universe
here is all the possible IP addresses
all right good so formally what would
you like to solve this is our distinct
elements problem single pass over the
stream data items assume that thus they
come from some Universal sizes 10 and
the size of this university know what
what is some good approximation to the
number of distinct element help me deny
denote the number of distinct elements
by K so we want to output some cake fat
she's not good at before okay
sandwiched between 1 minus epsilon K and
1 plus epsilon K and for constant
epsilon we want to have storage only
polar logarithmic in poly logarithmic in
end okay we also want success
probability at least 1 minus Delta for
some parameter Delta turns out that such
algorithms have to be randomized so we
have to tolerate some success profit as
in some feeler probability all right
very nice so let me remind you how how
such such as how such questions are
solved and this would be a nice way of
introducing sketching techniques so it
turns out that it's easier to think
about the decision version of this
problem name we don't try to approximate
the number K of distinct elements but
rather just try to solve the problem of
given a threshold T and the datastream
figure out have you seen more than T
distinct elements or here than T
distinct elements that is what an
algorithm that if the number of distinct
elements is bigger than 1 plus epsilon T
says yes if it's smaller than 1 minus
epsilon T says no if we have such a
thing we can easily run this algorithm
on a sequence of geometric thresholds
and we will be able to get our
multiplicative approximation just check
when the answers switch from yes to no
and output that note
all right and this will not really
affect our space complexity by much
because it's only a lager with a log in
the in the universe size and some
dependence on the position good ok well
how do we solve this problems with a
classical approach to this is as follows
mmm
so here's our frequency vector
representation of the data stream and we
have a parameter T we'll want to know if
we have seen more than T distinct
elements or fewer than G distinct
elements what we do is this we select a
random set s subset of the universe that
includes every given element of the
universe independently with probability
1 over T and so here it is this red set
for instance for this particular case it
contains the numbers 3 & 6 and now as
the algorithm is scanning the stream the
algorithm will simply maintain a 1
counter as and the counter will be the
summation over all elements I in S this
special red set of X I so if X I here is
the number of times the I fella meant to
write so basically this is the vector X
ok well note that of course you can't
compute this number but you can maintain
it because as an item arrives an arrival
of an item can be interpreted as a
request to increment X I by 1 so this
can be easily maintained in the data
stream and takes only one word of
storage well at the end of the string if
we observe that the counter is positive
we output yes if the counter is zero we
all know and this indeed sounds
reasonable because we wanted to know if
the number of distinct elements is
bigger than t1 will the counter be
positive what will be positive when the
set s intersects the set of distinct
elements in the industry and if s is the
size of the if the number of distinct
elements is large this random set will
probably intersect the distinct elements
so the count will be positive and we'll
say yes otherwise we say no
all right good so this is our basic
decision version and from this decision
from the solution to the decision
version for the distinct elements
problem it's quite easy to get the full
out indeed this is what we do we choose
a uniformly random subset s and maintain
a counter well and it is not too hard to
verify that indeed if the number of
distinct elements is substantially
higher than key let's say bigger than 1
plus epsilon times T then the
probability that the counter will be 0
at the end of the day is somewhat small
indeed what's the probability that the
country is 0 it's the probability that
none of the distinct elements make it
into our random set it's about 1 minus 1
over T raised to the power K so that's
roughly to the minus K by T and if K is
bigger than 1 plus epsilon times T then
that's a little bit smaller than 1 over
e if K is smaller than 1 minus epsilon
times T this is a little bit bigger than
1 1 already very nice so one round of
this can give us a little bit of a
signal as to how big the number of
distinct elements is in order to boost
this into a high confidence algorithm
all that we need to do is just maintain
maintain these estimators for uniformly
random sets and look at look at the
statistics of the union of these
estimators if substantially if if more
than K by EPSA v we maintain a certain
number of these estimators if a large
number of them say yes we say that the
number of distinct elements are small
otherwise we say that it's big
okay yes sir you see really the numbers
that you see a troika different
uniformly at random for the intellisense
oh good question so the question was the
is it do are we making this assumption
that the numbers that we see are
uniformly random let me see good you
mean the numbers that we are actually
observing in the stream no we're not
making this assumption correct we are
not making this assumption so note that
the stream is basically isn't one-to-one
correspondence to this frequency vector
X okay there's the ordering as well but
our algorithm maintains counters so the
order it doesn't really matter so this
this result holds for any choice of the
data stream right so this is actually
exactly the reason why we choose a
uniformly random set right so for
example if I knew that the actual
identities of the distinct elements were
uniformly random I wouldn't need to
choose the random set s here I could
have just chosen a fixed set s and then
the same types of bounds would would
have all it would have helped
any other questions [ __ ] when you
transition to the decision version of
the problem yes you choose tea by doing
a search but it's a screaming algorithm
in ten months
no a great question the question was why
is the decision version enough okay so
what I said here was that if we have a
small space algorithm for solving the
decision version then we can get the
multiplicative approximation from this
this algorithm why well it's just run
around a logarithmic number of instances
of this algorithm in parallel right
specifically you choose all the
thresholds or geometric sequence of
thresholds between 1 and n that
increment by a factor of 1 plus epsilon
and at the end we maintain all of these
algorithms the end of the day we ask for
each and every one of them well is the
answer more than T and then we look at
the answers that they give well
presumably what will happen is that for
small T's they will be saying yes at
some point they will uniformly switch to
no we just look at look at the look at
the largest threshold for which
everything below said yes ok good so the
space complexity does not depend on T X
excellent question yes so note that the
space complexity is oblivious to T the
only thing that T controls is you know
which rate do we how big of a set s do
we take is if I want to know if the
number of distinct elements is big is
bigger than T I should be looking at the
restriction of my stream to a uniformly
random subset of size about n by T so
that with some probability I get a
signal basically do I have an
intersection or do I not
yes there a way to determine on this
efficient version of this second course
you need to use oh yes good thank you so
here of course I said I said let's
choose a uniformly random set s and as a
Clemente is pointing out that this looks
a little bit expensive because as stated
if I count this the the space that I the
number of bits that I need to store the
actual random set it's a uniformly
random set so I need Omega and bits for
instance if my threshold is a constant
so that's that's a problem however one
can redo the analysis using
pseudo-random number generators
basically in in reality what we would do
is take a pseudo-random set and there
are general-purpose techniques that say
that for instance if you have a space
bounded algorithm that relies on linear
sketching then you can pretty much do
the analysis assuming that you have a
purely random set and then invoke a
powerful tool such as for instance nice
on pseudo-random number generator that
shows that if your analysis establishes
correctness of the algorithm under the
assumption of a purely random set then
the algorithm will work with high
probability if you instead of that feed
at a pseudo random set and the pseudo
random set can let me generate it in
small space might be worth mentioning
that this s can just be pairwise
independent
um okay good good
it is also indeed good to mention that
this s can almost be pairwise
independent the way I phrased this
analysis it actually cannot be because
in order to say that the probability of
the country being 0 is 1 minus 1 over T
to the K actually did rely on full
independence however so in this
particular case you can use a similar
pseudo-random number generator that's a
general purpose tool that says if your
algorithm works assuming perfect
randomness and use a small amount of
space that you can fool it you can give
a cheap randomness and it will work as
is or equivalently or related
development you can redo the analysis
assuming that s is the set S is
generated using a pairwise independent
hash function the analysis will have to
change a little bit because in this case
the probability of a counter being 0 is
not 1 minus 1 over T to the K so some
space bounds will change a bit but
morally it will all be the same all
right very good
other questions
all right very nice good so this is this
is our our very simple of one of the
classical algorithms in the screening
literature we first got this estimator
which is intersects the set of distinct
elements with a random set and checks if
the intersection is zero or not and this
can be done by using a single counter
and then if this only gives you a slight
signal namely the probability of being 0
and non 0 is different when the number
of the distinct elements is large or
small and then you boost the signal by
independent repetition just run one over
epsilon squared times log 1 over Delta
copies of this algorithm and see how
many of the algorithms say yes and say
no yes I'm just curious the way would it
be like sort of summing as counters it
seems very more general than you're
speaking of here are you going to that
sending a header as soon as I again I
like the way I would pray this is
probably not to do that but like this
saying that uh like what something seen
or not but you've said 0 4 is greater
than 0 as if leading in the neck
excellent questions so the question was
why are we summing some encounters
because really the only thing that we
used was was the scoundrel 0 was it
nonzero yes and indeed if my stream only
contains insertions if elements only
arrived and never depart I would be able
to easily solve those instead of using a
word of space I would take Kriegers a
bit of space and I would equally well
solve the problem and this indeed is is
hinting towards the the next part and
this is really what these two talks are
about the algorithm that we obtained has
a very nice property namely it can be
seen as basically what it does it takes
linear measurements of the frequency
vector of the data stream so number we
have the data stream with items arriving
and one can represent it as a vector X
were the 8th coordinate of X is just how
many times X arrived so far so because
our algorithm was summing there was a
sum over x i's
in fact it can be seen as a linear
operation and in particular this means
that if our stream is more general in
particular some items arrives and
sometimes items get to depart so we
delete items from the stream the
algorithm works as is good it works as
is only half as long as X is not
negative at the end of the stream so if
X gets to be positive or negative than
this particular thing okay good so
summary this is a simple example of a
linear sketching algorithm for data
streams our algorithm generates a
sketching matrix s this is a matrix with
M rows and n columns and is the universe
size in this case and if M is some small
parameter for this particular algorithm
it's basically a Polliwog uh and when
now as the elements of the data stream
arrive our algorithm maintains the
matrix matrix vector product s times X
which is B and whenever it's asked to
provide the answer it runs some kind of
a decoding primitive on the summary here
so note that the number of rows times
log m is the space complexity because
we're assuming that all operations are
both are on fully unbounded integers
good
so what we just did was approximate the
number of distinct elements in a stream
mm-hmm which is also known as the l0
norm of the vector the frequency vector
X a national question to ask her which
has been asked in the literature it's a
classical question is whether or not we
can approximate P norms of the frequency
vector X for other values of P and what
is the space complexity of approximating
station off we've known for example that
the information norm is the is the max
systems the most frequent item and the
l0 norm is the number of distinct
elements
good so this is known as the frequency
moment question the P frequency moment
is just the peak norm of the frequency
vector X raise to power P
okay so question is how much space is
needed for 1 plus epsilon approximation
to the peace peace nor of a vector X
let's say for constant epsilon and it
turns out very nice result that poly
logarithmic space and space comfortable
to what we have just obtained suffices
for Opie's between 0 and 2 actually
including 0 as we have just seen but
polynomial space is needed whenever P is
bigger than 2
so we just yes is there any intuition
once such a sharp shift to see aha great
the question was is there some intuition
behind this phase transition at P equals
to I guess one one one one version of
generating intuition is the for all P is
between 0 and 2 or F P stable
distributions exist namely for instance
the Gaussian distribution is too stable
right as an if you have if you sum up
independent gaussians with some variable
X is that be stable if the sum of alpha
ixi is distributed as the norm of alpha
times X so for example the Gaussian
distribution is too stable but these
stable distributions exist for P is
smaller than 2 and they do not exist for
P is bigger than 2 and I would say that
probably reasonable intuition for why
they do not exist is the central limit
theorem because therefore P is greater
than 2 you have to have variance on them
so if you have to converge to the
Gaussian but that's just intuition
good
yes are there schemes that have she
would read lower back yes there are
schemes that the trophy achieve with
some poly locks
yes so that this is all this is as usual
pretty tight bounds are known for all of
these questions
okay good good so we just designed an
algorithm for one of the extreme cases
namely P equals zero for a few moments a
beef moment estimation let me remind you
or tell you how you would approximate
the beef moment or for the other extreme
aiming for people's - yes suppose our
goal is this we have a data stream
arriving and we think of X as the
frequency vector of this data stream and
we want to approximately compute the l2
norm of of this frequency vector there
are good reasons for that for instance
this is known as Jeanne's surprise index
you can think of the l2 norm of a
frequency vector for data stream sort of
a measure of how skewed the distribution
of data items on the stream is since if
you have one outlier than that that
occurs a lot of times it will affect the
l2 norm
hello okay so good suppose that we want
to approximate the l2 norm how do we do
that well the classical approach also
known as the AMS sketch for a long
matias integrity is to generate
uniformly random signed vectors r1
through RN be iid random variables that
are uniformly random signs so RI is plus
1 or minus 1 independently with
probability 1/2 and now as the data
items are coming in the algorithm or our
algorithm would maintain the following
dot product we just maintain the dot
product of this random sign vector with
the frequency vector of the data stream
so let's call that Z so this is easy to
maintain under increments or decrements
off of X it's not hard to verify that
this is an unbiased estimator as we
output Z squared this is going to be an
unbiased estimator for the l2 norm
squared ah and now the actual algorithm
simply takes an average of let's say log
1 over the failure probability divided
by precision squared independent runs
independent such estimators and then
outputs this average
now this is also known as the Johnson
Linda starts transform I guess the more
standard way of phrasing this would be
with gaussians but for streaming
applications it's easier to deal with
plus minus 1 vectors and furthermore as
before one doesn't really want in order
to approximate the l2 norm to assume
that these sign vectors are uniformly
random one can get away with the bounded
independence is just four wise
independent suffices for the purposes of
this analysis and such random variables
can be generated cheaply
good told me summarize
we have just defined a couple of
classical algorithms for data stream
applications and specifically two
algorithms one for approximating the l0
norm and the other for approximating the
l2 norm of a frequency vector of a data
stream and both of them operate in the
linear sketching framework namely they
generate the random sketching matrix S
with a small number of rows and then
maintain as the increments or decrements
as items arrive or depart in the stream
the matrix vector product s times X very
good if I want to approximate the l2
norm of the frequency vector then my
matrix s is basically just a matrix of
random plus minus ones and the decoding
is just take averages for example if I
have enough independence if I want to
approximate the l0 norm then what I do
is I generate a matrix s to be the
matrix of zeros and ones sampled from a
geometric at a geometric grid and the
decoding that just takes medians very
nice so it not follows I will show how
techniques of this of this type can be
used to approximate graph parameters in
data streams in particular we'll see how
with techniques similar to l0 enormous
dimension can lead to space efficient
algorithms for constructing spanning
forests of graphs in streams where edges
can be both inserted and deleted and oh
that's interesting and in the second
part I will talk about how techniques
are held how l2 style techniques let us
approximate orders design algorithms
that approximate the spectral spectrum
of the graph when data streams one edges
get to arrive or depart
okay good all right so this brings me to
our graph sketching before I go to graph
sketching let me define the basic graph
streaming model so this basic graph
streaming model is the following now we
think of the algorithm as the receiving
a stream of data items but the data
items are edges of a graph so here is
our input
it's an undirected graph G and I will
only talk about unweighted graphs the we
think of the vertices of the graph as
being known so let's say vertices are
numbers one through n there are n
vertices and M edges M could be as large
as N squared here the vertices shown as
green dots on the slide now the edges of
the graph arrive in some arbitrary order
in a stream something like this and as
the algorithm is scanning the stream it
is constrained to use a small amount of
space alright so before when we were
talking about approximating basic
statistics of frequency vectors and data
streams the small amount of space was
poly logarithmic waves or for shooting
for poly logarithmic space algorithms
now here in graph streaming it is
customary to assume that the space that
the algorithm has available is at least
linear in the number of vertices in
particular we observe assume the minimum
possible also known as n poly log n if
there are good reasons for that and the
reasons are that often for questions
that we want to solve on graph streams
the algorithm does need at least n space
to just store the output for example
imagine trying to compute a spanning
tree of a graph just output sizes M so
you need about n log M 2 to store the
output to be able to output at some
point or maybe you're trying to computer
matching a large matching in the graph
so the output size again could be easily
comparable to the number of vertices in
the graph
ok so we're assuming that we have tilde
of n space so tilde stands for and only
log N and ideally we want single path
algorithms take a single pass output the
answer so this is known as an insertion
only stream and in insertion only
streams of even basic questions that the
connectivity actually turn out to
require a linear space so an assertion
only means
yes so for now let's think about only
adding edges so let's so let's consider
a very simple problem very simple graph
problem on insertion all my streams I'm
getting as input a set of edges of a
graph and I want to construct a spanning
tree or maybe a spanning forest there is
no guarantee that the graph is connected
well that's very easy as the edges come
on I simply maintain a spanning forest
and I will always the forest will never
be more than never contain more than n
minus 1 edges so my space complexity
will be n log n so suppose that lets say
an edge arrives if it connects two
components two fresh components I keep
the edge if an edge arrives and connects
to two vertices that are in the same
component I don't keep the edge so this
goes on and on and at the end of the
stream I didn't do I do get a spanning
tree of the graph very nice that is very
easy but suppose now that we still want
to construct a spanning tree of the
graph but edges can be both inserted and
deleted and it does happen in networks
that change dynamically over time so is
it possible to construct spanning trees
of graphs in dynamically changing
network so this both with edge
insertions and deletions and still do
this in the optimal n log n space or or
and poly log n space
well the problem turns out to be a
moment of contemplation reveals that we
cannot can no longer get away with a
very simple algorithm well suppose that
we have this graph here and if you look
at this graph then this edge is a bridge
and any spanning tree of the graph will
definitely have to keep this edge on the
other hand in a stream with insertions
and deletions the following can easily
happen or maybe at some point I received
this graph in the stream and after that
I receive a lot more edges that cross
this particular cut and my algorithm
still needs to maintain some small space
summary ah so at this point in the
stream when I added a bunch of edges the
red edge that used to be important
before does not look important anymore
so if I think of as algorithm that
stores and poly log and bits of space at
this point there is no good reason why
it would be interested in this edge on
the other hand I do get to delete edges
so let me construct a stream where a ton
of edges are inserted that go across
this cut and not at some point deleted
so this is interesting how can we design
an algorithm that still retains
information about this red edge despite
the fact that in the middle of the
stream this edge was not important at
all okay good so it's clear that very
different algorithms are needed and
that's exactly where sketching comes in
bit of linear sketching as we have seen
is a very nice parameter because if I'm
able to design a linear sketching style
algorithm for my data stream problem
then this algorithm seamlessly
translates to the setting where edges
can be both insurgent and deleted and
this brings us to graph sketching
so girls caching is the following idea
hmm
this is an idea introduced by an goofin
McGregor in 2012 and the main idea here
is to apply classical sketching
techniques such as the ones that we just
looked at namely distinct elements or
AMS sketches on the edge incidence
matrix of our input graph so here is the
input graph pictured on the slide and
let me remind you of the edge incidence
matrix says here's the edge incidence
matrix will denoted by B it's a matrix
width and choose two probes one row for
each potential edge in the graph and n
columns the columns correspond to
vertices in the graph now each row in
this matrix is a potential edge in my
graph G
so for example if if an edge is in the
graph so for instance here's this orange
edge if the edges in the graph and igv
then the corresponding row of the edge
incidence matrix is nothing but Caillou
- Caillou Caillou is the indicator
vector it is the coordinate vector in
direction you in other words for edges
that exist the row contains a 1 at 1 at
the endpoints and a minus 1 at the other
basically we think of first orienting
the graph and then the UV edge of the UV
throw matrix will contain a minus 1 at
you and a plus 1/3 and the orientation
is arbitrary it doesn't really matter
ok now if the edge is not in the graph
then the corresponding row is 0 so here
examples of two rows of the agents
No okay now what
so what is this powerful property of the
edge incidence matrix that helps with
rough sketching the very nice property
is the following
mm well note the suppose that I have a
graph and I want to approximate the cut
structure of this graph for instance
here's a graph on the slide and suppose
I want to understand how many edges go
across a cut s so I have a set s of a
subset s of vertices and I'm interested
in the number of edges that cross the
cut to go from s 2 minus s so here on
slide the cut is to the bottom to the
top of this red red line
all right it is convenient for our
purposes to encode a cut through the
indicator vector of it off of the cut
the 4 cut s a subset of vertices
let's X be the indicator of that subset
of notes so X is no vector of length n
that has a 1 on for all positions
corresponding to the two vertices in s
and a 0 otherwise so this is equivalent
to just assigning binary labels to
vertices of the graph vertices on one
side this is the S side of the cut get a
1 vertices on the other side of a cut of
the cut get a 0
well the nice observation that underlies
graph sketching primitives is that B
times X is the signed indicator vector
of the cut dealt office
indeed if I pick an edge say this edge
here that crosses the cut then B ties
times X's what B times X right
multiplying the vector B by X B times X
will be a 1 plus plus a 1 times 1 at the
endpoints well 0 times the other
endpoint and if maybe if if if one of
the endpoints of the edge is inside the
cut and the other is not then X zeroes
out one of the endpoints and keeps the
other so I get a 1 or a minus 1 and if
both endpoints of the edge are inside
the cut then the plus 1 and a minus 1
cancel if both of the endpoints are
outside of the cuts well I'm multiplying
by zeros anyway all right good so B
times X is a signed indicator of off the
set of edges ended now that's this
happens to be a very powerful
observation and in particular this
observation allows us to solve the
following interesting problem suppose
that I receive a sequence of edge
updates insertions or deletions and at
the end of the stream I'm given given
some cut s right I didn't know it before
the stream arrived and what I want is to
be able at the end of the stream when
I'm presented with this cut to output an
approximation to the number of edges
that cross the cut
okay if I knew the cutter in advance
that would be easy because I would just
ignore all the edges that that don't
cross the cut well I don't know we come
back ah
so for instance for this cut I should be
able to output something roughly equal
to two and for this cut I should be able
to output something about equal to seven
all right
how do I do that well one way of doing
this is to look at the edge incidence
matrix B of the graph and as the edges
come in main maintained S times B which
is a matrix which with a poly
logarithmic number of rows and n columns
so it's a small it's a pretty small
matrix here it is ah
once I receive the cut I simply decode
an AMS sketch of the corresponding cut
so have the matrix be wishes n choose 2
by n and at the end of the day I'm given
a cut s and I'm asked to output a good
approximation to the set of two the
number of edges that cross the cut how
would I do this I would generate an AMS
sketch for instance
which is a matrix with a poly
logarithmic number of rows and and
choose two columns s will be like this
and as the edges in the stream are
coming in I will maintain the product s
times B okay so this product yes oh yes
thank you thank you so let's say right
let me call this D Prime
so suppose I'm givin a cut see at the
end of the at the end of the stream and
I want to output the good approximation
to the number of edges that cross this
cut all I do is generate an AMS sketch s
and then as the edges of the graph come
in I maintain s times B and that's easy
to maintain because an edge update is
simply an update to one row of B so I
can maintain this very cheaply at the
end of the day what I know is that B
times the indicator of C is the
scientific go across the cut so B times
one the indicator of C is a vector in RN
choose to where I have ones of plus or
ones of my minus ones of plus ones on
all the edges that cross the cut and
zeros everywhere else on the other hand
so in particular the l2 squared norm of
this lecture is nothing but the number
of edges that cross the cut so if I have
an AMS sketch off of this vector then
I'm able to get a good multiplicative
approximation to the edge of square
known of the vector which is also known
as the number of edges that cross the
cut okay on the other hand I already
maintained s times B this is make me a
matrix with a poly logarithmic number of
rows and n columns so as soon as I'm
given this set set C of the cut that I
want to estimate all I need to do is
just write multiply my sketch s times B
with the indicator of this cut this
gives me the sketch of B times 1 C and I
just decode this sketch to produce an
approximation to the cut
so this basically relies on the
following observation this relies on the
observation that the set of the vectors
that are indicators of cuts form a
linear subspace of dimension and and
what were n n minus 1 and what we're
doing here is sketching the basis
vectors for the subspace and then later
we can recombine the sketches of the
basis vectors into a sketch for the cut
that we want yes
a great question yes that's exactly what
we do you see
so as the edges arrive in the stream we
don't know what sea will be yet so we
will maintain s times B because we can
do it this is a small object only poly
logarithmic number of rows and n columns
and then once we're given a cut C we
simply add up the corresponding columns
of this matrix and by linearity we
actually have a sketch of B times the
indicators other questions
yes
so this is the sketch approximating cuts
to know if they're approximates other
like other sort important vectors so if
it I mean if it's a zero one vector
your Pike space big time oh yes so this
works for any for any vectors yes I will
get that's the second part second point
to talk yes the vectors don't have to be
binary it's just for binary lectures
this has a very nice combinatorial
interpretation mmm good all right
very nice so this already looks looks
quite looks quite powerful
and this is the idea introduced by
unhooking McGregor let me summarize so
we first designed very simple nice
linear sketching algorithms for basic
statistical estimation problems namely
distinct elements in the AMS sketch what
is happening there is that we have a
vector X this is the frequency vector of
the stream and our algorithm maintains
the matrix vector product s times X this
is a vector with a small number of
coefficients in a small dimension in
graph sketching what has worked
extremely well so far is the idea of
sketching the edge incidence matrix B so
here's the matrix B which is n choose 2
by M and we hit it on the left with the
sketching matrix S with a Polliwog
number of rows and n choose 2 columns
and again as before this matrix s is
large but we can generate it using a
pseudo-random number generator so this
can be generated in a small amount of
space
and so in graph sketching what we
maintain is a matrix just end columns
one per vertex and the poly logarithmic
number of rows so think of really just
doing standard sketching operations on
the on every on a per vertex basis and
so the fact that the edge incidence
matrix has this nice plus minus 1 has
set the Plus Ones and minus ones leads
to powerful cancellations ok nice so we
have a
algorithm that lets us approximate any
given cut at the end of the street and
by the way of course this algorithm also
extends to the question of approximating
any polynomial number of cuts instance
if at the end of the stream I don't give
you one cut but I give you some poly n
number of cuts or you can just use the
AMS sketch and set the failure
probability to be inverse poly n and the
sketch will be simultaneously correct
and all the cuts unfortunately it will
not be correct on it all will be correct
on on that polynomial set of cuts
unfortunately it won't be correct on all
the cuts simultaneously because there
are too many of them ah ok so in
particular this doesn't really give give
us an algorithm for constructing
spanning forest okay but here's the
algorithm that actually does construct
spanning forests in graphs with the
dynamic edge updates using linear sketch
this is the algorithm of wan-koo
McGregor from Sodor 12 well first we
start with a simple algorithm for
constructing spanning force also known
as Broca's Albert well we initialize our
forest to the empty set and we start by
initializing our set of connected
components to singleton components all
the vertices and then the process
proceeds over a logarithmic number of
rounds and in each round what we do is
the following
we look at every connected component in
the graph so far and for every connected
component we look at the corresponding
cut that separates that vertices in that
component from the rest and choose one
edge every component selects one edge
from this country very nice then we look
at the set of edges recompute the news
planning forests and and proceed so for
example maybe in round one these two
vertices chose each other of these these
two vertices chose each other and the
situation
okay if this is what happens in round
one then around - we have three
connected components and then every
connected component now selects one edge
from the corresponding cut and we have a
spanning tree if our graph learners good
a moment of contemplation reveals that a
basic step in this algorithm is the
operation of sampling and nonzero entry
in the following vector at this point
here given a collection of vertices in
the original graph given a cut what we
need to do is choose one edge from the
graph that crosses the cut now
specifically oh we know that the we know
that if we look at the edge incidence
matrix B and multiply it on the right by
the indicator vector of that particular
cut what we'll get is a vector with the
Boston plus 1 or minus ones on the edges
that cross the cut various so it'll be
very nice if we could design a primitive
that selects a uniformly random doesn't
really have to be a uniformly random
selects an element of the support of B
times the indicator of some set of
vertices good well luckily this has been
studied in the literature and this is
known as l0 samplers defined l0 samplers
for you and then we'll get a sketching
algorithm for connected so a delta error
l0 sampler is the following
object it's a linear sketch just also
known as as a Rand as a distribution of
matrices that Maps vectors in dimension
n2 vectors in some small dimension m and
the sketch comes together with a
decoding primitive thus decoding
primitive takes vectors in small
dimension and think of em as poly log
compression and the decoder spits out
one element of the universe and this is
going to be the nonzero element
okay so the sketch together with Dakota
is an l0 sampler if for every X in RM
with the integer poly unbounded entries
the following is true if we decode the
sketch of X then the distribution of
this one element of the universe that we
get is close to the uniform distribution
on the non-zeros of X interpolation
Delta close informally think of this as
follows this is a randomized algorithm
that either samples uniformly random
element of the support of X or outputs
fail or just some garbage with
probability Delta and think of Delta
small so both probability Dalton can
just break and not tell you that it
broke or it can break and tell you that
it broke okay this has received quite a
lot of attention and the in the
literature recently and we actually know
tight bounds for the space complexity of
at least l0 samplers good so now
equipped with this notion of l0 samplers
we can actually get a connectivity
algorithm for dynamic graph streams and
the connectivity algorithm will do
exactly this well we will go through the
natural algorithm or the brokers
algorithm that constructs a spanning
forest and a logarithmic number of steps
by the way the number of steps is
logarithmic because the number of
connected components goes down by a
factor of 2 at least in every step and
we do the following so at every point in
time we needed this primitive for taking
a subset of the vertices and selecting
one outgoing edge from the cut well
that's exactly what l0 samplers do how
many times will we need to do this well
we know that the algorithm will run for
order log n steps so let's prepare
sketches let's prepare l0 samplers ls1
through s T so T is order log n with an
upper bound on the number of a number of
iterations of this out now as the graph
as the edges of the graph are coming in
our algorithm will maintain as 1 times B
as 2 times V through s T times B
independent l0 sampling sketches for for
the edge incidence matrix all right so
now the one in iteration T the algorithm
needs to sample an edge from from a
certain cut we just run the l0 sampler
on the sketched version so we take the
sketch boss multiply it on the right by
the by the indicator of the vertices in
the cut and run the decode okay and as
long as our decoder succeeds which we
can control by setting this failure
probability to be small this is a
connectivity algorithm for dynamic
graphs okay there is this is quite
surprising because of note for instance
that the algorithm is highly adaptive we
don't really know up front which cuts
will emerge as intermediate components
in the run of this algorithm
there is the algorithm is adaptive and
runs over a logarithmic number of rounds
but the sketch is not adaptive we are
using the fact that of cuts form a
linear subspace we sketch the basis
vectors and then we can recombine
sketches of these basis vectors to get a
schedule for whatever we want okay one
other interesting question is why did we
need independent sketches for every
round of the streaming algorithm well
that is because these sketches cannot be
used adaptively if you think about the
definition of an l0 sampler okay so a
very natural improvement to the
algorithm before would have been to just
sample one sketchiness instead of T
sketches and use that very same sketch
in in every round of the process that is
not guaranteed to work why because of
the definition of l0 samplers and l0
sampler is an object that for any given
input vector with high probability
produces the correct result if we use
the sketches adaptively then the vectors
on which we wrong become correlated with
the randomness that the sketch users and
the correctness properties break
although it turns out that in fact a
limited amount of an activity is okay
when we use
user l0 samplers and that's how one can
get optimal lower bombs for the space
complexity of failures a very
interesting way quite recently a Nelson
and you showed that showed an optimal
space lower bound for any spanning for a
sketch of that of the type that we have
seen in particular if for this sketch if
you set the parameters right and use the
the best known of optimal l0 samplers
then the space complexity will be an
lock you band bits and this turns out to
be needed good um there are some simple
implications of the spanning fourth
sketch let me just list them one one one
nice and simple implication is that if
we just don't just want to spanning
forest but suppose I want the following
primitive I have a parameter D and I
want to list all edges in my graph that
have connectivity at most D ok well
actually not quite that I want to find a
list of edges that will contain all the
edges of connectivity at most D you can
do that in about n times D space simply
keep keep D spanning for sketches take
out one spanning forest subtract it from
the remaining sketches by linearity you
can do that and repeat so that way you
have adaptively take out D spank for us
from the graph and the list of edges
that you obtain will contain all edges
with some work well one can also obtain
cuts Parsa fires from from this
primitive
okay let me just say a few words about
how one would design l0 samplers in
particular this this is in fact a fairly
simple construction that follows the
techniques that we used in distinct
element sketches okay
so Delta aero l0 sampler is this
randomized linear sketch with the
decoding primitive that essentially with
probability 1 minus Delta spits out a
uniformly random element of the support
and otherwise breaks
so basically we want to take a little
sketch that allows us to scan a stream
and at the end of the day she was one of
the elements of the support uniformly at
random and not be biased towards the
ones that appeared very often how do we
construct such linear sketches all right
main idea is quite simple well first
suppose that our input vector is one
sparse that was actually there is
exactly one element of the support and
we call that X is the frequency vector
of the stream well that's the case then
we can recover X by sparse recovery
using just two rows of sketching matrix
I will show these two simple rosin okay
very nice so if X is one sparse then we
know how to solve the problem and in
particular l0 sampler just needs to
output that one element so that's good
on the other hand if X is t sparse for
some T greater than one then here's what
we can do similarly similarly to the
distinct element sketch we can imagine
first choosing a uniformly random subset
of the domain every element is included
with probability 1 over T but if excells
T sparse then with a non trivial with
constant probability X restricted to a
random subset of size about T actually
will be one spot and we can solve the
problem there and if it is one sparse
the element that remains is a uniformly
random element if they're doing so good
things will happen so I said that I said
that if X is one sparse then I can
recover very I can reconstruct X just
from dot products with two rows of a
sketching matrix so let me tell me tell
you how well the two rows are one row
with just a once and the other row with
1 2 3 4 5 through n ok if X has a single
nonzero then X is just the coordinate
vector in some direction I star times
the coefficient so it's not hard to see
that I can read off the coefficient from
the first dot product and I can further
read off the direction from the second
mmm good so if X is not sparse as I just
said we can imagine rounding at sparsity
to the closest to a power of two and
choose a uniformly random subset that
contains every element with probability
2 to the minus J responding rate and
with constant probability this will be
one sparse and we can recover this there
are some small details to be to be
filled in for example that we can
actually verify that recovery was
successful but let me not dwell on that
ok it seems that I don't have time to
talk about the lower bounds but also let
me skip this and good
just a quick summary I showed how to
design l0 samplers and besides l0
samplers some other basic sketching
techniques that are meant for simple
statistics of large data streams and
showed how these techniques can be
applied to the edge incidence matrix of
graphs to get non-trivial graph recovery
primitives namely standing forests with
dynamic dynamic updates and optimal
space in the next part I will talk about
other methods namely of classical
methods for finding l2 heavy elements in
data streams and I will show how these
methods can be applied to achieve a
spectral of spectral sketches for graphs
mainly right now we just recovered
spanning forests I will show how to use
l2 based techniques to recover spectral
approximations namely approximations
that will get most of the aisles eigen
values of the laplacian matrix correctly
to than multiplicative factors and
generally preserve the quadratic form
[Applause]
yes I see so the question is can we not
run broke at the end but rather sort of
around Brusco as the bluff is coming in
oh I see so that seems tricky because in
a sense I can construct a spanning
forest and then some edge is deleted and
now presumably I need to oh I see so
you're saying can we also get a quick
update procedure that would be nice III
wonder I suspect that some of these
caching techniques have actually been
used in similar settings but I don't
know if I don't know and you could
answer to this yeah that sounds like a
good idea so maybe one can speed up the
maintenance of the forest yeah that
would be nice
right
yeah both media application for l1
ingress l1 on
that is a good question but I don't know
an answer to it
ah no so at the moment we only write so
in a sense l2 basically is I don't know
a good application at the moment l2
based techniques give you a spectral
sparsa fires which are strictly stronger
than cut Sparsit fires so it's not clear
that one would do would help you here
it will be nice to find some but I just
want the number of connected components
okay in dynamic streams I see search
very dynamic edge updates and I just
need a dent oh I see so I leave way
would probably be do you still need
three logs or you need you need at least
you do need an Omega n you do need so
the space complexity will be between
Omega n and analog cubed
ah n log n for the number of connected
components
is an N log in again I thought it was
just M I'm okay I think I only know they
home again but yeah I see I'm not aware
for an algorithm that does this with the
smaller space complexity sounds like an
excellent question but the question is
can you do it with a small space yeah
so there's an Omega n lower bound right
so you can't do this in some linear
space right so that's
what does your question
I think in if you very in session I mean
you just want to know the number of the
number of components sure so you would
need at least and space for that yeah
right so the quick all right so the
question is with Ken's question is how
many bits of space do you need for for
dynamic graph streams if you just want
the number of connected components the
answer for all I know is somewhere
between n bits of space and a lot cube
bits of space but I don't think we have
techniques for doing it okay then maybe
I don't know okay
any other questions
[Applause]